already during his
student days, hegel was admonished several times for playing excessive cards and drinking too much red
wine he is undoubtedly one
of the most unconventional today one would
say coolest thinker ever it is
mocked
he would have discovered the world spirit in addiction
but his
explanation of the world is still fascinating and
top notch  -aktuell jäger was the first to recognize the
dimension of becoming in all its
scope
he can rightly be called the charles
darwin of philosophy because
everything really everything hegel says is in
constant motion human life
has just as much a process character as
nature and history  a human being
is born as an infant, becomes a
child, becomes an adolescent, and finally becomes an
adult and
human history progresses from the simplest
beginnings
one epoch follows the next if we speak casually of
the so-called zeitgeist these days, we are
missing the point of
hegel  cover back that every time has
its own all-pervading
spirit this zeitgeist or as
hegel would also say the world spirit shows
itself in the respective convictions of the
people of morality justice
fashion art music architecture
but that's just not enough
he still does  a second
momentous discovery the different intellectual forms
and historical epochs he
claims are not randomly strung
together but follow a
logical movement principle of the
so-called dialectical the pendulum of
history swings dialectically sometimes in
this sometimes in the other direction
but nevertheless mankind steers
slowly and unstoppably  on your big
goal the book rules the 60 minutes
explains using the best quotes how
dialectics and thus the motor of
human history work
many books claim to be able to explain the
difficult philosophers hegel well
this w  really the
exciting questions that emerge from his
fascinating philosophy
are all answered where does the
story end are we just spectators or
players we or what is the
world spirit what is the meaning of life
what is useful and hegel's discovery today